Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I am going to explain the British science
fiction film called “Frequencies.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
The movie is set in a dystopian world where
every person emits a specific frequency which
determines his or her luck, further determining
his or her success in life.
Higher frequency means better luck and thus
less feelings.
The movie starts as we see some students standing
in a single line; each holding a single green
apple.
Marie Curie Fortune, a bright young girl,
is one of the students in the line.
The student behind her drops his apple and
she very calmly returns it back to him.
The scene then cuts to the students sitting
at their desks preparing for an exam as their
teacher gives them instructions and tells
them to begin.
Just then, all the students put on their respective
blindfolds and begin working on the test.
After the test is over, the teacher announces
their names individually and hands them their
results.
Outside, the students discuss the result among
themselves.
Marie Curie proudly boasts her score of 127
while her friends receive scores far lower
than hers.
One of Marie’s arrogant friends then introduces
her to Issac Newton Mitchell, who introduces
himself to Marie as Zak.
Marie is told that Zak has a frequency of
minus 7.
The arrogant friend wanted them to meet as
they have exact opposite frequencies, extreme
high and extreme low.
As they stare at each other, it starts raining
abruptly.
The teacher then calls Zack as her mother
had come to meet ger.
It turns out that high frequency people and
low frequency people repel each other.
From the moment Zak met Marie to the time
the teacher calls Zak back was exactly one
minute, which means they can only be in contact
for not more than one minute.
Marie’s parents are concerned that their
daughter will never be like other children
because of her complete lack of empathy.
They visit one of her teachers to discuss
their queries.
The teacher clears that because of her extremely
high frequency and high luck, she has less
feelings.
When asked if she can live a normal life like
others, the teacher says that it won't be
possible at all.
Fastforward into the future and we see an
older teenage Marie presenting her science
project to the same teacher; Miss Anderson.
It is a device that can analyse frequencies
of 2 opposite sex people and tell if they
are compatible or not.
The therapist praises her ingenuity and says
that it might also help people make friends
and that she herself should try to use it.
This prompts Marie to then perform several
experiments to find out whether two people
with very different frequencies can ever have
a meaningful connection or if there is a way
for someone to increase their frequency.
She chooses a test subject that has a frequency
on the lower end of the spectrum; Zak.
In the first experiment, she interrogates
Zak who is very awkward with the answers.
As the clock ticks 60 seconds, an aeroplane
starts dropping luggage onto Zak, which he
narrowly evades.
Thus, proving the theory that 2 people from
extreme opposite frequencies cant stay together
for more than a minute.
Miss Anderson comes onto the scene and warns
Marie that frequencies cannot be changed.
In the subsequent experiments, she meets Zak
for exactly one minute and catalogues everything
that he says to her.
It is clear from his behaviour that Zak is
interested in Marie but can never seem to
get across to her.
Also, in each of the experiments, the duo
get separated before the 1 minute threshold.
Finally, Zak confesses that he loves her and
asks her if she feels that same.
She responds by saying that she is incapable
of feeling anything because of her condition.
She continues that she shows emotions only
to pretend in front of others.
However, her goal is to one day feel emotions.
The movie then again fast forwards in time;
this time to when Marie is an adult.
It shows how her daily life plays out with
her performing everyday tasks in the same
emotionless state.
When she is resting at home, her friends and
family come over to give her a surprise birthday
party.
She sits alone during the party until she
is approached by Zak.
They talk briefly until Zak reminds her that
the clock has crossed 60 seconds.
He then says that he has found a way to help
her and thus she agrees to meet with him.
Later, the duo meet at a place.
Zak reveals that he lasted more than a minute
the last time because he increased his frequency.
He then tells Marie that there is a way for
her to be able to connect with other people;
by lowering her energy levels.
He explains that it will require physical
contact.
She is skeptical at first but since she is
eager to experience some form of emotions,
she lays her hand on the table and then Zak
grasps it in his.
Marie is completely overwhelmed, she feels
something but cannot describe it because she
doesn’t know what it feels like to experience
emotion.
She feels unwell and lets go of his hand but
realises that holding hands had actually made
her feel better.
Since they have been talking for way more
than the designated 60 seconds, nature begins
to rebel and Marie, feeling overwhelmed, kisses
Zak.
We then experience the story from Zak’s
perspective.
The boy at the beginning who dropped the apple
was Zak himself and he liked Marie from the
start.
When the teacher calls in Zak from the playground
to meet his mother, it was so that they could
discuss his future in the institute with Miss
Anderson.
She recommends that Zak be shifted to a different
facility because his frequency is too low
and that he will never fit in with the others.
Zak adamantly refuses.
After the ordeal, Zak makes his way to Theo's
house, his only friend.
When he gets to the house he is met by Theo’s
father who shows him that he has skills different
from everyone else's because of his ability
to use imagination.
This is manifested when he finds that he is
excellent with the piano, because of his ability
to see the piano progressions.
With Theo, he learns that he cannot be with
Marie because a high energy person and a low
energy person create magnetic fields that
repel each other and cause destruction.
The movie then fast forwards to Zak’s teenage
years where he, like Marie, is presenting
a project at the science fair.
Marie comes to his station and asks to meet
him after school.
Both of them clearly have different agendas.
Marie wants to experiment on Zak while Zak,
determined to improve his frequency, tries
his best to establish contact with Marie.
We see that to increase his own frequency,
Zak, with the help of Theo, uses magnets to
temporarily boost his frequency.
Zak experimented with different substances
before each meeting with Marie to see which
would have the most desirable effect.
However, they didn’t help much as Marie
admitted to feeling nothing for Zak.
Fast Forward again to when Zak is an adult.
He presents a groundbreaking theory that redefines
the concept of frequencies.
He tells the professors that even high frequency
people can experience emotion if they believe
in it.
Unfortunately for him, no one buys his idea.
Zak again meets with Theo to find ways to
improve his frequency.
They experiment with different compounds but
unexpectedly realise that particular sound
waves can boost frequency for a short period
of time.
To test this hypothesis, he is sent by Theo
to meet Marie at her birthday party.
While departing, Theo gives him a device with
code words to activate the sound waves, thus
giving him an additional 5 seconds more this
time.
During their conversation, he’s also wearing
a microphone through which he can hear Theo
giving him new words.
Everything comes back full circle when both
of them kiss.
The intimacy has the effect of reducing Marie’s
frequency and quelling the revolt of nature.
The couple then make love for the first time.
All this while, Zak keeps getting the secret
words on his device, which extends his time
with Marie.
They begin to spend more time together.
During their time together, Marie experiences
some bouts of unluckiness, such as missing
her train.
This is a clear sign that her frequency is
dwindling.
She then makes a bold move and takes Zak to
visit her parents.
Her parents, in many ways, are high frequency
individuals like her.
So they are concerned that when an average
boy comes into their house, the frequency
mismatch would cause a rebellion of nature.
Marie ensures them that it will not happen
and then the entire family has dinner together.
At the table, Zak explains to Marie’s father
how the concept of harmonizing frequencies
works.
He explains that nature will always seek balance
so that high frequency and low frequency people
can be together because the low frequency
individual will receive some of the energy
of the high frequency individual.
This will cause uniformity and everyone can
be the same level.
He then presents his device to Marie’s father
and explains how it works.
It basically takes the frequency mismatch
between the people in the surroundings and
presents a two syllable word that can help
balance out the frequency.
Marie’s father is very excited to hear that
a device can be used to achieve complete balance.
He believes that the device would render the
concept of high energy and low energy to be
useless, thus giving everyone justice.
In fact Marie’s father is so confident in
the idea of universal balance that he puts
together a research team to improve the device’s
functionality.
The team consists of some of Zak’s old school
mates.
However, they soon discover a strange side
effect.
If one asks anyone to do anything after saying
the two syllable word, they will do it involuntarily.
While Zak and Marie’s father try to figure
out how to fix the glitch, Marie comes to
a realization that when Zak met her at her
birthday, he was using carefully selected
words to lower her frequency.
Then, with the two syllable word and a meek
request, he subconsciously compelled her to
fall in love with him.
Marie’s father is furious at Zak for manipulating
her daughter like that.
To his defence, Zak says that he had no knowledge
of the side effect and that the entire thing
was a misunderstanding.
Needless to say, Marie’s father disbands
the team and makes everyone sign a contract
to drop the idea of experimenting with the
device.
He also forbids Zak from seeing Marie again.
One day, upon returning to his room, Zak finds
some men in his room.
One of the men says that they are from the
government.
He even has the same device that Zak invented.
The man then asks Zak three questions and
he can only respond by nodding his head.
Zak realises that the questions the man was
asking were phrased in such a way that they
would ensure he was telling the truth.
Zak doesn’t understand how that is possible
because no one else was prive to the work
they had been doing with his device.
The man then offers Zak a job.
After Zak reaches the secret place, the man
explains that the government has set up a
secret team.
He stresses that the team needs to neutralize
the threat, known as the manual, which is
the name given to the two syllable generator
device.
The team consists of the team that Marie’s
father set up before, since only they knew
how it worked.
The government agent then tells them the story
of how this technology had surfaced up several
times in the past and caused devastation but
had always been obscured from the public to
keep the balance and peace.
He knew that it would inevitably be rediscovered
and that, again, they would have to bury it
in secrecy.
Over the next few days, the team works very
diligently trying to figure out how to overcome
this problem.
They all put forth their ideas, suggestions
and mathematical models to resolve it but
never make it to a consensus.
Meanwhile, Marie’s father is still cold
to Zak.
Zak then suggests making an anti manual, one
that is flawed so that its perception in the
public is tainted and people are less likely
to be inclined to use it.
Also, he realises that from his study of patterns,
there must be some antidote words to nullify
the effect of the glitching words.
All of them stick to this theory to try it
out.
They end up producing words that implicate
harmless commands but can only be used once
every hour.
The government official isn’t pleased to
replace one havoc causing word with another
and so he bans the words immediately.
Later, at the request of Marie, Zak utters
a word from the device along with a command
so that Marie will fall out of love with him.
However, she says that nothing’s changed.
When the government agent comes to know that
Zak tried manipulation again, he is locked
into confinement and is forbidden to speak
with anyone.
In this state of solitary however, Zak’s
mind begins to wander the depth of his knowledge
and procure everything he knows on the subject
to find a solution; an antidote.
Thoughts and cacophonous sounds whizz past
his mind until the solution becomes clear
to him.
He knows where to find the antidote.
Desperate to find the antidote, Zak lures
the guard into his room and utters a single
word that freezes him in place.
He then escapes the secret facility.
He makes his way to Theo’s father’s home
where he knows he will find the antidote.
Theo’s dad realises that Zak has figured
it out and offers to help him.
Marie also arrives at the scene and informs
him that he has less time.
Just then, the government officials strom
the place and restrain Zak.
Suddenly, Theo’s dad begins playing a melody
on his piano.
When asked what he is doing, he replies that
he is simply giving them the antidote.
He then challenges them to use any word while
he is playing.
The government official does so and to their
surprise, it makes no difference.
Theo’s dad then reveals that when Mozart
plays, everyone is the same frequency.
He continues by saying that music neutralizes
the power of the words and that Mozart immunized
people against the book that contained the
words.
In short, music resets everything.
The final segment is shown from Theo’s perspective.
It is revealed that he was the one who dropped
the apple so that Zak could talk to Marie.
It is also revealed that Theo has exactly
average frequency.
What follows is an interesting dynamic between
Theo and his dad.
His dad believes that humans can escape the
entrapment of machine like thinking by using
imagination and their concept of free will.
Theo, on the other hand, believes that all
humans are machines and they can be very predictable.
All of Theo’s work during the course of
the movie had reflected this very mindset;
from his helping Zak control frequencies to
his science project that was obstructed by
the Zak- Marie attraction.
Elsewhere, Marie and Zak are together and
get their results back from the doctor, who
gives them doses of Mozart, Bach and Pachbell
as medicines.
The doctor also confirms that Marie’s feelings
are not due to manipulation.
The movie ends on a high note when Theo believes
he has figured out the universal symphony,
a complete knowledge of things that will allow
him to predict how any interaction or event
is going to happen.
So, that leaves the question, did anyone in
the movie ever have a free will or were they
just the product of their frequencies.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thanks for watching.